thanks for being here first of all thank
you for having me the premiere episode
of Siesta Key was very surprising mostly
because of you and this new relationship
that you are in how has it been to watch
the reaction to that it's but overall I
think I've had I mean from fans at least
they've been very supportive yeah my
friends and family are another thank you
really yeah yeah yeah yeah there's still
I mean it's I realize now it's going to
take a while I thought you know okay
I'll come in everyone will have their
immediate reactions and then you know
they'll get over it but it is a bigger
bombshell than I realize yeah and it is
taking some time why do you think that
is is it because he was a producer on
the first season is it because of the
age or what what's the biggest concern
it's obviously like a combination of
yeah for my family at least I think it's
the age yeah and then for my friends I
think it's with a producer because they
knew him before but in a different way
yeah how long have you guys been dating
now cuz on social media it looks like
you're still together we are okay
together um it's been about a year now
Wow yeah over over a year yeah okay well
there is a clip that we have from
tonight's episode where you tell your
dad okay time I get to see this play out
on camera so it'll be weird
let's take a look okay so I think I owe
you my sincerity to say that at this
point I'm not convinced that this isn't
my daughter's best interest
you do not have a pool you don't I think
it's a mistake to Lowell this guy is
gonna be an old man when you're 39 years
old
how would that to film that was really
hard that was really hard you know it's
obviously a hard conversation to have
anyway and I think I have to give the
show credit and production credit that
it was all caught very organically on
camera and you know also I have to give
ish props for coming into the situation
you know easily could have said no why
did he say yes because he knew that this
is my life and I have agreed to do this
on camera
mm-hmm and I've agreed to be truthful
about my life and he wants to be with me
and he so he said all right whatever you
want to do I'm all-in you said that your
friends in the family are a different
situation when it comes to this
relationship obviously your dad is
saying he doesn't approve who doesn't
love the age gap where exactly does your
dad stand right now he is
I mean he's coming around slowly but he
and I I think I needed to give him more
time than I was initially wanting to I
wanted you know obviously I want my dad
to approve I want him to welcome my
relationship with open arms and I didn't
get that and I'm still working on it but
I'm learning that I need to also get him
some space and some time with that and I
can't just expect him to come around
right away but hopefully I mean it's
working in that direction we're excited
we're making progress
so do you think there is a day in the
near future far distant future where he
accepts ish wholeheartedly yes yeah I
did maybe I'm being naive and hopeful
but I do okay it has to he has to right
well that depends on how you feel about
ish to like is this a guy that you see
marriage with that you see kids with one
day is are you thinking about it it is
yeah and I mean I watched my my sister
is gay so like I watched my dad come
around
that that wasn't the easiest and so he's
like you know he's traditional he's old
but like I seen him be very open-minded
when it comes to me and my sisters and
so like I have to believe that he will
come around once he sees no I'm happy
and in love yeah well I think as parents
we want to believe that no matter who
your kid chooses to date gay straight
age whatever that they will accept and
that they will love and I think it's
kind of brave of you guys to really put
this because we've never seen anything
like that's really on reality television
we're a producer sort of comes on the
show and dates one of the leads right
yeah and I mean to be fair it was not
you were never dating when we kept it
very professional when he was on season
one there was no crossing lines at all
okay I didn't even see each other for
over a year after he was off the show so
when leaving the show had nothing to do
with no absolutely not okay absolutely
not we have seen you in different
relationships on the show so what is
different about this one this one feels
a lot more mature and there's probably a
reason because he's 46 years old yeah
but there's just it it feels like solid
yeah and you know he obviously knows
what he wants and I feel very confident
that I know what I want I know I'm still
young and I know I will grow but I want
to grow with ish mm-hmm and he wants
that too so when you guys talk about the
future like what are those conversations
like um it's now it's a lot like what a
family where are we gonna live like the
big questions it's like you know if
we're gonna talk about those things no
better time than now yeah Dean if it's
if it's that if that's not in the cards
for us then I think it needs to end
sooner than later right so like these so
no one's wasting their time yeah yeah do
you think an engagement is coming could
we see that on the show you won't see it
on the show yet okay um but yeah at some
point so it's an active conversation
yeah okay are you thinking 2020
maybe Wow oh I do have to say like I
like how giddy you are when you're
talking about him like you seem to be
smiling
yes he's a good guy he makes me happy
someone who's not too happy is Brandon
seemingly no kind of walking me through
yeah we saw his reaction where do you
guys stand now are you friends at least
we're good yeah yeah I mean I will
always respect Brandon and I think he
would say the same about me
we actually watched this premiere
together and - were side-by-side taking
shots together so it's a great progress
okay that is actually a lot of progress
yeah I think so I was just thinking the
same room together civilly it's nice no
it was I I don't know I feel bad for
Brandon but he's doing well in his love
life he's a lot going on is he dating
anyone right now he is yes yeah his
ex-girlfriend Camilla they're now
together back together so the whole
Amanda thing is not she might pop back
up but is it like the extended trailer
that we saw where you're sort of calling
out Brandon because you don't really
trust Amanda yeah and he says to you
like it's not fair yeah totally
yeah which he had every right to say
that to me but why did you say that to
him though because I was it wasn't cuz
you were still like having lingering
feelings you just really felt not great
about no I do think that there were
lingering feelings not like romantically
but I definitely felt hurt by it okay I
definitely felt like it was a little
spiteful mm-hmm and also do we have to
keep dating each other's friends like
does this group have sickness like we do
all sort of date yeah so yeah I mean I
was like annoyed and and he's right I
don't get to say anything but I'm sort
of yeah you were seemingly sort of
teetering with the idea of getting back
together with Brandon on point but I
think fans felt really conflicted about
that because he had cheated on you yeah
so were you legitimately considering it
um yeah I mean we did legitimate you
consider I don't know that I gave it the
full amount of effort that he did
I think he really did want to get back
together and I was like yeah mostly
because like I needed closure and I
don't think it was gonna work out at all
yeah cuz of fidelity yeah and I feel
like once that happens it's hard to
really move past yeah that do you think
that he still regrets that I'm sure he'd
who wouldn't regret like just cheating
publicly yeah yeah yeah yeah no i yeah I
know he does I know he feels very bad
about it okay
however they hopefully he won't do it
again and his other relationships you're
right hopefully he's learned no it was
really young too and people make
mistakes not to excuse cheating by any
means but no I know it's nice to see how
you guys sort of did overcome yeah in a
way yeah how are we gonna see ish
integrate more into the cast well you
will see me drag him along to our
parties so he's around quite a lot then
yeah yeah for a while on a TV because he
is a producer so he was working on other
shows so he could only be around so much
but when I could get him down to the key
definitely yeah
take me back to the moment where things
turned romantic for the first time like
what was it about him well okay so I
always had like a schoolgirl crush on
him yeah but why like what was it I
don't know very attractive and like
charismatic I don't know okay everyone
on our show loved him like you heard
Juliet say like they've always gotten
along he was like the cool producers
thanks guys he also yelled at us a lot
but no I don't know I always had like it
would mean it was like a little crush it
was nothing no big deal and then when I
came to LA I reached out to him I
pursued him Wow yeah and she was
resistant for a while just kind of like
I mean the age obviously and also she
knew that this is a weird situation and
didn't want it to seem something that
wasn't yeah so it took a while I
definitely pursued him
and then he came around we started
hanging out and then from there I think
it moved pretty quickly yeah started
saying I love you was like pretty early
on Wow okay so this is like full-on
we're in love yeah were endgame this is
yeah I think it had to be for him to
take her I think once he decided like he
was gonna come on the show for me I
think he had to have known at that point
what are your living situations like
right now is he are you out here with
him are you I think he went to Canada
yeah he was in Canada doing like a
seventh month long seventh month long
show okay um
but he is based in LA and I'm still in
CST key there's a lot of commuting or
you know back and forth yeah yeah
bicoastal and so I mean I try to get out
here when I can he tries to get out
there when you can is that hard to do
long-distance essentially yeah yeah it
is hard especially you know when we are
on a reality show and so everyone has
their two cents
everyone constantly is like moving the
story forward and you know there are
lots of opinions how do you mute that
that noise it's tough it's tough it's
really tough and I'm still learning but
I think just the fact that we have
survived this long is a testament
because as you know there are a lot of
relationships and the key that don't
survive and it's you know I mean having
a camera there it's just like having the
rest of the world put their two cents in
as well yeah you're sort of welcoming
that either praise or criticism which I
heard maybe when you saw some of the
criticisms from your loved ones did you
ever think like maybe this isn't right
for me maybe I should break up with him
um yeah you did okay
yeah because obviously like I I want my
family to be happy and to support me so
that was the hardest you know one buy
like but my friends came around pretty
quickly so that was wonderful having
their support
mm-hmm but yeah it was it was tough
having my family not approve
but I know you're hopeful that they're
gonna come in well yeah well I do want
to shift gears just a tiny bit to the
Alex expecting a child situation yeah
how did you receive the news or how did
you take it so we all found out well
Chloe had found out firsthand from Alex
and then she came and told all of us of
course she did so I think we were all
incredibly shocked just did not expect
it at all at all do you think he's gonna
be a good dad I think he'll be a good
dad I think he will step up and help me
a good dad I've seen him with his
younger siblings and he's very good with
them do you think he's going to be a
changed man when it comes to the
relationship I'm hopeful I am hopeful
that this will be what he needed in the
promo we actually see you say that
you're late wait there is a scare I
won't tell you what exactly happened or
what the outcome waves but yes is that
was in time yeah I was gonna say how is
that gonna be to rewatch that um it's
gonna be hard for sure it's definitely
one of the more emotional things I went
through on the show this season know
always be watching that I mean but in
some ways it might be therapeutic oh
okay oh my gosh I'm so curious now I
have so many questions but I know you
can't really reveal I I get that
anything that you are nervous to see
play out maybe aside from that moment um
the season I think just everything with
ish there's more drama with ash later on
like well yeah something big happens so
I you know I I hope that you know it
doesn't create any waves in our current
relationship like watching back oh oh do
you think about that sort of how that's
gonna look there sometimes we're like I
said something about a friend that I
don't leave anymore but it's like oh my
god I have to rerun
now and then you have to sort of address
it for them yeah text ebook hey I'm
sorry
it does feel like you guys have a pretty
solid solid friend group though and you
guys all kind of get it but it causes
how are you right now with the rest of
the cast is everything intact yeah yeah
I think right now we're all in a really
good place with each other which is
funny just in time for it to air and
mess everything up again of course
that's how it always goes yeah anything
you're excited to see play out the
season I'm really excited for just all
the friendships and I think seeing
Juliet grow is huge this season I think
she goes through a big change and I
think everyone will enjoy seeing her
grow up do you think that the alux news
is what sort of triggered that she I
think she was going through like her own
self growth before that okay just
attribute it to Alex like I think she
she did this on her own
yeah yeah I talked to her earlier and
she did seem like she has learned write
a lot yeah yeah she's in a good place I
think and your guys's friendship is good
yeah okay
and how's Kelsey Chloe I don't know if
Kelsey and Chloe will ever be good but
everyone is very civil right now okay
yeah we're still all good friends all
right well thank you so much for being
here thank you you guys who are watching
siesta key airs Tuesday nights on MTV
it's so juicy the season so make sure
that you tune in and yeah I really
appreciate you being here thank you
[Music]